what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up with the immortal
hulk now one thing to know we are
only a handful of issues out until this
thing ends right i think we have
what is this this is technically july so
i think we have
august september and october so we got
three issues left until this whole thing
is finished and it's all wrapped up and
done so i'm really excited to see
where this ends because i'm you know let
me know down in the comments i'm curious
what y'all's take is
on the immortal hulk run up to this
point but in this video we're covering
what is basically the secret origin
of joe fixit hulk now one of the things
to keep in mind when it comes to joe fix
it
is that what you had originally at
marvel comics as most of you guys know
is you had the incredible hulk who was
gray and a lot of that was because they
just didn't want him to tie into any
kind of racial ethnicity or anything
like that but the difficulties that came
with
making the incredible hulk gray in color
basically couldn't be overcome so they
ended up making him green
now years later under uh peter david's
run with the incredible hulk 347 they
brought the grey hulk back but call him
joe fix it
and the incontinuity explanation is that
technically the very first variation of
the incredible hulk we saw
was actually joe fix at hulk hence the
reason why he was grey but the geofixit
persona took a backseat to the savage
hulk persona which is why he turned to
green
and so it was a pretty neat way to kind
of wrap those things up but the reality
is we never really seem to get a tried
and true
explanation of joe fix it and so a lot
of this really seems to cope with that
now
one of the things this does here is it
kind of has a bit of a flashback with
regards to betty ross and all that kind
of stuff a bit of the history there
between her and bruce and anybody who's
been reading the incredible hulk for any
measure of time will tell you
their relationship is tumultuous at best
[Laughter]
right they have been lovers and they
have been head over heels for each other
and there's been times where they've
been at each other's throats right they
just absolutely want to kill each other
really good example of that was red
she-hulk versus the incredible hulk
right but the whole thing behind this is
that a lot of what happened with betty
ross the struggle she went through
a lot of even the even the death of her
character was all based on her
experiences with the incredible hulk if
bruce spanner had not become the hulk
she wouldn't have endured
all those different things and a lot of
this is designed to kind of juxtapose
things right the idea that in the early
days when she was talking to her dad oh
you know don't be unfair to bruce
spanner you know he's a cool guy
everything's gonna be fine you know no
matter what happens i'm sure he knows
what he's doing
all the while kind of giving us this
this you know these kind of panels that
show us that yes they got married and
their life basically went to crap and
she ended up dying then came back as red
she-hulk and then
all this kind of crazy stuff right he
basically turned her life upside down
and all this really kind of segues into
what is one of the most
weird moments of probably any incredible
hulk series ever
when you've basically got red harpy
right betty ross
in bed with joe fix at hulk imbued with
the power of the red hulk it's weird
it's a little strange but it's kind of
cool right because there's a little bit
of banter that kind of goes back and
forth between the two but one of the
other funny things that really goes on
here
is that when betty turns back into
herself there's a big conversation
about the nature of bruce banner about
how she sees bruce how she's seen him
for quite some time
and how she sees joe fix it and the way
this works is that
bruce has in a lot of ways kind of
pushed betty away that it's one of these
things where he's come
to her for aid but he's also pushed her
away and a lot of it's subject to
whatever it is that he happens to be
going through at the time and it really
all kind of boiled down to this
mentality of
bruce doesn't want betty exposed to the
life that he lives in but he doesn't
want to live without her and so how do
you square that circle right how do you
keep somebody safe from this life that
you live but at the same time
keep them close by you and a lot of ways
you can't and that's one of the reasons
why you saw these saw a lot of these
instances over the course of the
incredible hulk mythos right bill matlow
peter david uh greg pack jason aaron all
these guys where it was basically bruce
banner in a lot of ways pushing betty
ross away but at the same time also
trying to keep her close right this kind
of tug of war
that went on and for her it was
exceedingly frustrating and exceedingly
irritating
more so than that she hasn't seen bruce
banner for quite some time
that he hasn't appeared to her and had
any real kind of conversation with her
now
a lot of what's gone on recently if you
guys have been following our coverage of
the immortal hulk is that bruce banner's
in hell
so he can't he can't hang out with her
he can't spend time with her but even
when that wasn't the case
he just didn't really like her and and
the reason why was because she was a
mirror for bruce when you look at it if
we kind of go the the route of like bill
matlow and peter david and look at it as
a more introspective philosophical
approach to the reason why bruce was
this way
it's because when betty ross was just
betty ross she was a normal human
she represented everything that made
bruce banner's life
pure and great and perfect this idea
that he could return to a state of
normalcy
and this chaotic life that he led but
when the time came when betty ross died
suddenly bruce banner lost everything
that was pure and great in his life when
she returned as the red she-hulk
any chance he had of normalcy was
stripped away when she didn't want to
have anything to do with him and seemed
to outright hate him
and then when she ended up becoming the
red harpy or at least returning back to
the red harpy and taking on this kind of
you know red she-hulk red harpy approach
then suddenly she was a mirror of all
the things that bruce spanner hated
about himself
i.e gamma radiation and the hulk and so
then he was basically avoiding her and
so it was one of these things where
consistently
any possibility he had with a great life
with betty returning to that kind of
pure
time when everything was perfect was
gone and betty ross looking at joe fix
it came to this realization that where
bruce spanner shied away from that
joe fixit embraced it and so in her mind
joe fix it basically saw her for who she
really was
and accepted it that in reality with
everything that she had gone through as
betty ross interprets it this harpy form
is who she really is right that's that's
who she really is the person on the
inside that's physically
manifested and joe fixit embraced that
and so in a lot of ways that kind of
acceptance
led to what she believed to be the
process of falling in love
the problem with this is that joe fixit
reveals his true colors here we all know
that joe fixit was
not a very good guy and that while he
does talk a big game in a lot of ways he
was kind of a coward and that's what he
reveals to her that
in this moment when he was whisked away
to hell and then everything was popping
off
all joe fix it cared about was trying to
find a way out right getting himself out
of there all the while
he knew bruce spanner was there but made
absolutely no effort to get bruce
spanner
out of hell and he tells her that he's
like look i mean you know the reason why
bruce hasn't been talking to you is
because he's in health and yes i was
there
and i could have saved him but at the
end of the day i just wanted to find a
way out and
she freaks she's like you left bruce in
hell
and immediately starts going off on it
right immediately starts losing it and
attacking him now you do kind of switch
over for a second between jennifer
walters and jackie mcgee of course as
you guys recall in the last video that
we did jennifer walters
essentially defected from the avengers
and joined the immortal hoax team which
was really kind of all gooing
essentially consolidating all the
members of the gamma radiated community
into one place but what she of course
does is take the phone of jackie mcgee
and then she basically hops on the old
fantastic four line now the reason why
this happens this is a great reference
by al ewing i love that he did this
jennifer walters was a member of the
fantastic four at one point in marvel
comics a lot of you guys may not know
that but there was a point when
different characters
shifted around and so you had characters
that would stand in for these guys
jennifer walters was one of them and so
because of the fact that that was the
case she has access to the kind of
fantastic four back channels right their
communication lines and she basically
sends off an encrypted message to ben
grimm
which says like the incredible hulk's
cool everything's okay i'm safe
i got everything under control the
question he asks to what is an effect an
entire assembly of
all the biggest heavy hitters in the in
the marvel universe right so all the
members of the fantastic four
and all the members of the avengers is
are we going to do the same thing
are we going to tell her that we're all
basically mustering our forces to launch
an attack on the immortal hulk and the
entirety of the the hulk family or do we
keep that to ourselves right now we
don't really get an answer to that
instead what we get
is basically the aftermath of of joe
fixed hulk revealing to jennifer walters
that he left bruce banner in hell and
essentially she lets him
have it right that she's kind of like
you so i've been operating under this
fall
false pretense this whole time this
whole time i thought you were a guy who
saw me for who i really was and all that
kind of stuff instead it turns out
you're just a coward and a dick like
really
you know and just just like lays into
this guy and where he apologizes her
response is no you don't know how to be
sorry right you want to look sorry but
that's just a camouflage to hide the
real you that you only care
about yourself and at that point she
writes him off and in the end he tries
to make up for this by kind of offering
an explanation and saying look you know
there's something that you need to
understand
about who i am right there's something
that you need to understand about who
like who i am as a person and where i
came from right that
i am simply just a version of the
incredible hulk that you ran across
one day just one of bruce banners alters
right as alternate personalities but
there's another thing that you need to
know here there was a kid like when
bruce banner was a little kid he was you
know
beaten by his father his mother was
beaten by his father but his life was
absolute turmoil and absolute health and
that while his father was sleeping it
off one night
while his mom wasn't there he watched a
black and white movie through
both of his black eyes that had just
been been made that way by his father
and somewhere in there was an idea of
what a grown-up is
somebody who could take the pain and he
says that's where i started from
now this is not a lengthy secret origin
here but it's
tragic as hell because one of the things
to know especially when it came to the
incredible hulk mythos for a lot of you
guys who are new
to the incredible hulk new to this
channel don't really know about a lot of
this stuff the old stories with stan lee
and jack kirby were straightforward
incredible hulk story right hulk just
smashing things he fights from people
the story ends and then you do it again
in the next issue
when it got to bill mantlow and peter
david especially really it started with
bill matlow and continued through peter
david it was very much an introspective
philosophical run
on what makes the incredible hulk the
incredible hulk how did banner become
the person that he was
did the incredible hulk just manifest
randomly because of gamma radiation
or is there something deeper than that
and one of the things that they really
built on there is that
everything the incredible hulk
represents is essentially the rage that
bruce banner fields towards his father
brian banner and that being left alone
is one part whenever the incredible hulk
says that
it's one part telling the people who
were there leave me alone and two
crying out to when he was a little kid
begging his father to leave him alone
the run of bill mantlow and peter david
you talk to anybody who knows anything
about the incredible hulk and they'll
tell you it's one of the most
significant runs in the history of the
character
because everything that you've seen with
the incredible hulk following those runs
is built on those ruts right every
concept that you've seen is predicated
on that right just because of the work
that was done and the things that went
into it and so
ty you know al ewing doing this ties
into that old stuff where it basically
really takes a page out of the stories
of bill matlow and peter david and it
says that like the notion of of bruce
banner
sure the savage hulk is a reflection of
the rage that he feels towards his
father
joe fix it the reason why he's so
hardcore the reason why
he's you know the guy you don't mess
around with why he has this kind of
intelligence but at the same time is
what you would define as kind of being a
man's man
is because it's predicated on a movie
that bruce spanner in his younger years
developed this alternate personality
because he wanted to be the kind of
person that could withstand the pain
that his father dished out to him
and that's why when things get really
really really really bad
sometimes joe fixit will manifest the
personality that takes over needs to be
the personality that can cast
everything aside emotional ties the
whole line yards and do what needs to be
done
and that's what joe fixit is right he is
a kind of romanticized perception
of what bruce banner thinks a man is
based on the movies that he's seen
so it's a it's a great concept right
it's a really really cool idea but at
the end of the day
and saying all that he says like it's
not really me that i'm in love with
anymore i don't want to be that person
anymore and when she's like so what what
does any of that mean he says i love you
right he's like that's what that means
is that i'm i'm in love with you right
like i joe fix it i'm in love with you
betty ross which i mean i under like the
whole motivation behind this it's it's
beautiful
looking at it is weird
joe fix it hulk like joe fix it hulk
with the power of the red hulk is saying
this to
a red harpy it's a little wonky but if
you can look past that
and kind of look at it as as two
personalities saying this then it makes
sense but at the end of the day betty
ross is like i don't know what to do
with this right
i don't know how to respond to this and
so she does the only thing that she can
do the only thing that she really knows
how to do
is that when he's spilling his heart and
saying like you make me want to be a
better man
like i know it was done to leave bruce
there but this time that i spend with
you this time that i'm around you
makes me realize all my shortcomings all
my mistakes and it makes me want to be
better
betty ross does what she always does she
runs she flees right she basically ends
up taking off
and so when joe fix it you know kind of
continues this conversation not
realizing that betty ross has taken off
and he's saying things like you know now
that i've come out during the day and
and i'm around people more i've learned
to understand people better i've learned
to grasp people better
so on and so forth and i've kind of
learned the error of my ways once he
asks her what she thinks
she's gone right she's totally taken off
and so he's like okay well then i guess
that kind of answers that question to a
degree and so
ultimately he ends up kind of stepping
out of the room because this whole thing
took place just in an apartment room
which is pretty cool you know i love i
love the idea when you have comic book
stories where the whole story takes
place in like a room
right it just takes place in like a
singular location because it's a real
testament to whether or not a writer
can write characters in a way that that
people can find receptive right can they
really understand those characters if
they can write them in what is an effect
a static location without a whole bunch
of action sequences and things to mask
the poor handling of the characters but
nonetheless al ewing of course as you
guys know writes
immortal hulk just stupidly well it's
ridiculous how good it is but when the
when the questions ask like what's the
plan like what what are we doing here
right i mean like
is there some goal that we have because
right now we're just hiding out from the
avengers on the fantastic four
what what what are we doing what's the
next step and the answer that joe fix it
has is
i'm gonna go to hell i'm gonna go to
hell i'm gonna face the one below all
and i'm gonna save bruce banner whether
i'm ready to do this or not it's cool
this is obviously leading up to
something
massive but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace